directo a madrid o iremos a la capital
española para hablar del anteproyecto de
ley que podría ampliar el derecho al
aborto y los derechos sexuales de las
mujeres este martes se cumplió el primer
paso que fue la aprobación del consejo
de ministros pero todavía falta la
revisión del poder judicial del consejo
de estado y de los legisladores una de
las reformas permitiría que las jóvenes
puedan abortar a partir de los 16 años
sin el permiso de sus padres aunque se
quedó por fuera uno de los temas más
pedidos rebajar el iva de los productos
de higiene femenina vamos a madrid con
nuestra corresponsal marina colorado
marina explíquenos por favor cuáles son
los puntos claves de la reforma que
impulsa el gobierno español
en españa es legal abortar desde
1985 pero mientras que esa primera ley
solo lo permitía en tres supuestos la
actual ley de 2010 ampliaba esta opción
a cualquier persona hasta la semana 14
la reforma que ha aprobado el consejo de
ministros del gobierno de españa y que
ha anunciado la ministra de igualdad
irene montero ataviada con un pañuelo
verde a la muñeca incluye algunas
novedades recupera el derecho de que
jóvenes de 16 y 17 años y mujeres con
discapacidad puedan abortar sin permiso
de sus progenitores o tutores legales
también elimina las 72 horas de
reflexión obligatorias en vigor en este
momento y regula la objeción de
conciencia para que siempre haya
personal disponible para practicar
abortos en las clínicas públicas ya que
debido a la objeción el 85 por ciento de
estas prácticas se deriva a clínicas
acreditadas privadas españa podría ser
un pionero en europa al reconocer bajas
laborales por menstruaciones dolorosas o
incapacitante es una práctica que ya
existe sobre todo en asia la reforma
también incorpora una baja de preparto
desde la semana 39 de embarazo que no
influye en la bajada y lo que no quedó
en el texto fue la reducción al 4 de
oliva a los productos de higiene
femenina que serán repartidos gratis así
como anticonceptivos de barrera en
centros de educación secundaria de salud
y prisiones y pretende incluir la
educación sexual desde etapas tempranas
de la infancia debido a la complejidad
del anteproyecto de ley y la diversidad
de los ministerios involucrados es
posible que esta ley no vea la luz hasta
el año que viene hasta 2023 marina y
cuéntenos cuáles han sido las reacciones
el principal partido de la oposición que
en 2015 había retirado la posibilidad de
que estas menores se pudieran abortar
sin autorización de sus padres ha
afirmado a través de su presidente que
si la ley prohíbe el consumo de alcohol
a menores de 18 parece razonable que se
solicite el permiso de los tutores
legales para la interrupción del
embarazo sin embargo hay que recalcar
que el 90% de las menores que acuden a
abortar ya suelen hacerlo acompañadas de
sus padres el partido de ultraderecha
español box y ambos sociópatas a los
impulsores de esta agenda política que
ellos califican de la agenda de la
destrucción de la vida humana algunos
han afirmado que la baja temporal por
las dolorosas podría crear un estigma
hacia la mujer o incluso interferir en
los procesos de selección laboral aunque
recordemos que está prohibido preguntar
acerca de este tipo de temáticas en los
procesos de selección en cuanto a la
eliminación del período de reflexión
expertos en salud la reciben
positivamente alegando que las mujeres
pueden pensarlo todo el tiempo que
quieran pero que el estado no puede
decidir por ellas cuánto y finalmente el
no rebajar los impuestos del 10 al 4% de
los productos de higiene decepcionó a la
ministra de igualdad que lo había
prometido durante la campaña electoral y
que quería acabar con la llamada pobreza
menstrual una medida que le había
costado tan sólo 30 millones de euros al
año al estado que es una parte ínfima de
lo recaudado por el iva en este sector
que en 2021 superó los 72 mil 400
millones de euros
harina gracias por la información y
nosotros seguimos con más aquí en
directo américa